hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control AC dot
l1-3.1.2 I know it's like a mouthful
right limit system access to the types
of transactions and functions that
authorized users are permitted to
execute
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist sp80171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I got great news for you if you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so the second control that everyone
has to solve for is a real head
scratcher all right the first time you
read it I mean honestly it sounds almost
like it's worded the exact same way as
the first control which I will not say
with that first control is because it's
like 15 letters all right no I'm just
kidding in fact it's not and what
they're looking for is very different so
let's break it down right uh today uh
today's question on cmscontrol
ac.l1-3.1.2 limit system access to the
types of transactions and functions that
authorized users are permit to execute
let's dive into what the assessors are
looking for let's dive into what some
sample answers might be all right
fortunately this one's only got two
different assessment points that they're
looking for evidence on right number one
determine if the types of transactions
and functions that authorized users are
permitted to execute are defined now if
we were to give a sample answer that we
might say something like hey
transactions and functions that are
authorized or defined and enforced via I
don't know maybe it's group policy and
system Access Control lists or ACLS
specifically you know in this case maybe
it's active directory in addition
certain transaction types and functions
are restricted by the endpoint
management solution and again an example
is anti-virus will not allow malicious
code to execute right so again
antivirus will not allow that type of
transaction or function to execute the
result and that's a limitation on the
system
now assessment Point number two
determinive system access is limited to
the defined types of transactions and
functions for authorized users so we
answer this one a couple ways right we
say system access is limited by ad right
little Active Directory Group Policy
system security policies those are
important too right I don't mean just
like the technical ones I mean like some
written policies too and conditional
access policies right so if we've got
our stuff up in say Azure government or
Office 365 GCC hi we're probably going
to use some conditional access policies
systems can only perform those
transactions and functions that are
allowed by policy otherwise they are
denied right so again that's an
important point is if it's not in the
policy it's excellent so it's denied
permit by exception now if you're still
scratching your head here's the good
news and on call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this defars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped into their lap
like a seagull on a sunny day we teach
you how to level up and be a proper
on-call compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps great areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you visit
cmmc complianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up in that like button
or even better smash that subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance starts
rolling out until the next compliance
tip my friends uh stay safe and secure
out there and hit us in the comments
below to let you let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
thank you